next question comes in from Trudy I've
been telling my story since 1990 I've
done a lot of training in the early 90s
and in my surveys I found eighty percent
liked the fact those using a story to
reinforce something twenty percent did
not do you have any advice so most
people are liking this you worry about
the other twenty percent he just keep
going on the 80 or can the stories be
better what would you tell Trudy I think
Trudy I think if you do a few things and
it probably was your story from the
nineties around connect in your heart in
your head connecting to the audience
being authentic making years stories
super clear you know making it hopefully
visual as well you've got eighty percent
love from your community I'll kind of go
after the other twenty percent I'm kind
of water they miss it because eighty
percent connected totally with your
story and that I'd say that's good
enough but you can always improve and
you know actually one of the interesting
thing one of our customer stories from a
company up in Oregon deschutes craft
brewery their kind of motto is do you
best and next time do better now they
build a they build a social enterprise
effectiveness business they're never
going to sell out to a conglomerate so
they are grounded by producing awesome
beer and every time they sell a crate of
beer they basically give a dollar to a
community charity so they've raised I
think last year a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in the communities
where they sold the beer but also
they've given every one of their
employees stock ownership in the company
to make a really clear statement that
we're all in this together with
following our dreams we're producing
awesome beer and we're going to play a
role giving back to the communities so
with that the reason why I tell you that
story is every time they do anything in
their business they want to make it
better so were those twenty percent that
you left behind why don't you know in
the world of the social media now you
could access every one of those
individuals and find out what is it what
is it they're missing in terms of the
connection with your story and and you
could get up into the high 90s and
touching a hundred percent I love it i
love you i love the drive and ambition
there yeah i think eighty percent is a
good
number if you're starting out 80 that
that's quality if you're if you're
speaking and you're moving eighty
percent of the room that's definitely
great start and I would just echo
stevens point there to like always try
to get better it's a good mark but let's
how do i get to 100 what do i have to do
to get there right how can my
storytelling be better whether it's his
advice of going out and trying to find
them on social media whether it's you
know recording your speech back and
watch it again and seeing where you
might be able to improve you know doing
surveys over the room trying to find
people who like left the room and ask
them what happened that can be a tough
pill to swallow like hey why did you
leave my session we hope it's the honest
kind of truthful advice that will help
you get better and you could do coaching
with other you know professional
speakers or speeching coaches to give
you guidance on how your next speech can
be better I think if you want to be good
at something then you should want to be
great at something and every time you do
it you may you may suck at the start but
the most important part is that you are
better than yesterday and you keep
working on and most people would start
with their stories it's uncomfortable to
start you feel like who wants to learn
about me you know and you have to
understand that you telling your story
isn't about you it's not an ego trip for
you it helps the customer connect to you
better it's for them and it's for your
business and so the start you will
probably be terrible telling your story
and then every time you do it you'll get
better and better and better and better
you move to eighty percent with a nine
percent hopefully move up to the hundred
percent